[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo on a trente minutes
pour faire le tour de l'actualité
politique et parlementaire au jo katia
bonjour michael notre invité eric woerth
bonjour bonjour vous êtes président de
la commission des finances de
l'assemblée nationale député les
républicains de l'oise ancien ministre
du budget et du travail dans les deux
premiers gouvernements de françois
fillon alors il y a beaucoup beaucoup
d'actualité a commenté avec vous d'abord
le budget acte 2 après le volet recettes
de l'état voulait sans encombre
l'assemblée examiné crédit débat animé
en séance le financement de la sécurité
sociale est aussi à l'ordre du jour avec
notamment l'une des mesures phares la
hausse de la csg et puis l'actualité
politique celle de votre parti des
républicains avec des décisions qui
tarde à venir et on commence bien
évidemment par le marathon budgétaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le premier budget défendue par le
gouvernement d'edouard philippe les
députés ont voté le volet recettes et un
certain nombre de points qui ont été
votées et on va voir tout cela avec
marion châtelain hormis les dossiers
clés du budget la réforme en profondeur
de l'isf l'impôt de solidarité sur la
fortune sera remplacé par l'impôt sur la
seule fortune immobilière dans
l'hémicycle les discussions ont été
tendus la gauche souhaite maintenir ce
dispositif la droite demandent sa
suppression pure et simple ou favoriser
les plus riches d'entre les riches c'est
à dire ceux qui concentrent le capital
mobilier et vous n'avez aucune garantie
que les ménages et des réaux
réorienteront leur épargne sur des start
up dans des fonds communs de
l'innovation ou sur l'investissement
dans l'appareil productif c'est un impôt
qui a nui me semble-t-il à la
compétitivité à l'attractivité notre
pays alors si c'est pas un bon impôt il
faut le supprimer
du côté de la majorité toujours le même
argument orienter l'épargné des français
aisés vers l'économie productive
nous allons libérer plus de 3 milliards
d'euros qui effectivement nous le
pensons iron va l'économie productive
nous faisons le choix de la liberté
nous faisons le choix de la confiance
nous faisons le choix du nouveau monde
fiscale et je pense que cela se traduira
demain par plus de croissance et plus
d'emploi autre mesure votée le
prélèvement forfaitaire unique à 30 %
sur les revenus du capital
les socialistes se sont inquiétés d'une
fuite des capitaux à l'étranger le
ministre de l'économie et des finances a
annoncé misé sur le bon sens des
français pour rendre cet axe efficace et
puis c'était une promesse de campagne
d'emmanuel macron la taxe d'habitation
sera supprimé pour 80% des foyers sur
trois ans cet impôt finançait une grande
partie des services publics des
collectivités territoriales l'état
promet de rembourser à l'euro près eric
woerth premier volet recettes adoptées
il ya eu cette taxe sur les dividendes
qui a été retoquée par le conseil
constitutionnel
ça nous coûtait 10 milliards pour la
france pour ce gouvernement est ce que
vous estimez que
du gouvernement d'ailleurs annoncé un
projet de loi de finances rectificative
dans les prochaines semaines est ce que
vous estimez que ce budget déjà caduc le
gouvernement annonce un projet de loi de
finances rectificative dans les
prochains jours puisqu'il avance il
avance en fait il ne il n'est pas des
mesures compensatoires de cette du
remboursement que le gouvernement doit
faire vis-à-vis des entreprises qui ont
indûment payé 7 cet axe il ne le met pas
les mesures dans le cadre budgétaire de
fin d'année mais enfin il est là il fait
un texte spécial alors il est peut-être
des raisons techniques c'est un peu long
pour les évoquer ici mais je pense
qu'ils aient surtout des raisons
politiques décident d'en faire un
élément de communication autour de
l'idée que d'un côté il va un
gouvernement socialiste qui a fauté et
de l'autre nouveau gouvernement dans un
monde nouveau dans le meilleur des
mondes d'aujourd'hui dont nouveaux
découvrent pas aujourd'hui cette taxe
non il réellement il aurait dû mieux
anticipé d'ailleurs plus provisionnée
dans les comptes de l'état il a
provisionné à peu près 5 milliards
d'euros s'ils récupèrent 5 milliards
d'euros sur les victimes de cette taxe
c'est à dire sur les entreprises
elles-mêmes
c'est le choix du gouvernement il aura à
s'expliquer avec les estimer que reprise
et les professionnels ce qui a été mis
en place ou pas c'est à l'époque à
l'époque et maintenant elle vous dit
qu'aujourd'hui je comprends ça procède
du même du même de la même précipitation
et une précipitation puisque cette taxe
de 3% sur les dividendes a été décidée
par gouvernement socialiste dans une
très grande précipitation
c'est ce qu'avait dit d'ailleurs gilles
carez à la commission des finances à
l'époque elle remplaçait une texte une
taxe qui elle-même avait été considérée
comme par pas l'égal d'une taxe ancien
une retenue à la source qui datait des
années 1980 très bien mais tout ça était
très précipitée aujourd'hui on est dans
une autre précipitations qui l
accélération du remboursement vis-à-vis
des entreprises donc les entreprises ont
payé 10 milliards de trop avec les
intérêts le gouvernement estime que
c'est aux entreprises de pays et d'une
certaine façon
donc ça c'est le choix du gouvernement
moi je conteste ce choix mais c'est le
choix du gouvernement
donc il invente une nouvelle taxe
probablement d'augmenter l'impôt sur le
sur les sociétés et il le fait aussi
dans la précipitation puisqu'il ne fait
pas en étant de façon en conservant le
rythme de la procédure budgétaire ce qui
est tout à fait possible et d'inscrire
ce texte dans le collectif budgétaire de
fin d'année csu à une précipitation
répond une autre précipitation est ce
que cette précipitation et ses choix
dont vous parlez vont contribuer à ne
pas à faire en sorte que nous ne
respections pas les 3% du déficit est
l'objectif affiché il et il est très
classe le gouvernement va le reste je
n'en sais rien je suis pas dans les
calculs de bercy dont je peux absolument
pas le dire et personne ne peut le dire
merci en tout cas c'est de l'argent qui
était inattendu mais enfin pas tant
inattendue que ça parce que depuis le
mois de mai y avait déjà une décision de
la cour de justice donc on pouvait
anticiper sur la décision de la cour de
du conseil constitutionnel donc il ya
pas de surprise pour le gouvernement ce
qui visiblement surprend le gouvernement
n'aurait peut-être pas dû l'être autant
que ça c'est qu'ils ont dit doivent
rembourser aussi vite et est autant
voilà donc je le gouvernement remplace
cet axe par une autre taxe et par une
surtaxe très forte un très puissante on
parle de 10 points de l'impôt sur les
sociétés pour les dut par les grandes
entreprises
je ne sais pas si une négocier sur vos
clients d'entreprise je ne sais pas ce
qui s'est dit entre le gouvernement et
les grandes entreprises
mais je vois en tout cas qu'il ya
beaucoup beaucoup de précipitation et je
pense qu'il ya une volonté d'organiser
une communication autour de sa de créer
une dramatisation autour de ça essayer
de montrer oui d'essayer de montrer
qu'un problème qu'on pourrait régler
tranquillement au mois de décembre doit
absolument être réglé au moins des
réalisations instrumentalisation
politique c'est ce qu'il ya une
instrumentalisation oui je je je je
pense une sorte de d'activisme fiscale
au travers de cette taxe pour montrer
comme le dit bruno le maire l'a dans les
documents que vous avez
panetta disant oui et non c'est
scandaleux d'état je sais c'est en tout
cas une très très mauvaise organisation
fiscale du gouvernement de françois
hollande dans lesquelles il y avait déjà
beaucoup de monde
il y avait déjà beaucoup de monde
emmanuel mâcon était le principal
conseiller économique du gouvernement de
françois hollande et qu'il y avait
pierre moscovici il y avait beaucoup de
monde donc de tout cela échoue et se
termine extrêmement mal mais je vois
qu'à tout cela le gouvernement décide
d'utiliser ça à fond pour essayer de
montrer je pas une sorte de moralisme
fiscale ou d'autres ou d'activistes ou
d'efficacité fiscal il pouvait le faire
beaucoup plus tranquillement sans en
faire un outil de communication comme il
le fait alors ces débats ont été très
animées en sur le projet de loi de
finances eric woerth mais aussi sur
justement en commission juste avant que
le démarre le débat en séance publique
je vous propose de revoir cette petite
séquence entre vous et vos anciens
collègues de votre formation politique
devenu ministre c'était le 27 septembre
dernier en commission des finances
extraits le premier budget présenté par
cette majorité ne respectent pas les
engagements européens de la france
il n'oubliera pas cher eric qu'en 2008
il y ait un nouveau président la
république qui est allé au conseil des
ministres des finances à bruxelles pour
expliquer que tous ses engagements
européens ça n'avait absolument aucune
importance et qui n'était pas question
que la france les respecte je te
rappelle que nous étions dans le même
gouvernement d'ailleurs jeu juste un
point que tu étais solidaire avec ces
mesures ces mesures là est la différence
était assez fondamentale en 2008 puisque
ont dit non non je ne me sens pas
notamment messieurs merci
merci j interviens met un terme à des
fautes je tenais dans votre attention
est dans mon rôle mais je peux aussi
créé un rôle je pense est là c'est le
cas la situation
enfin je pense que le rôle d'un
président enfin tout rôle politique
évolue en fonction des circonstances
politiques c'est vrai pour le président
de la république donc ça doit être vrai
me semble-t-il pour l'ensemble
finalement un monopole du président de
la république de changer les choses
donc je pense le président de la
commission des finances dans les
circonstances politiques qui sont les
mêmes qui sont celles d'aujourd'hui
son rôle doit un peu évolué il doit
garder évidemment une certaine distance
peuvent président et sa commission mais
je suis pas uniquement là pour inaugurer
les chrysanthèmes je suis là pas là
uniquement pour passer la parole et dire
ne roule pas bien vu ce que vous avez
passé de minutes sans cadran de
l'opposition et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
je suis président de cette commission
donc je donne mon opinion pas tout bas
toi sabrina mais bien sûr je donne mon
opinion mais je n'attaque pas bruno le
maire je donne mon opinion technique jeu
là sur le plan européen mais sur plein
d'autres
d'autres sujets mais mais où c'est le
gouvernement comme comme là vous l'avez
vu avec bruno bruno le maire
il passe son temps à dire qu'on est dans
le nouveau monde nouveau monde fiscal il
a inventé cela parce que tous les
nouveaux mondes se décline par chapitre
nouveau monde fiscales et sociales
nouveau monde sportif il ya des nouveaux
mondes partout bon mais surtout des
anciens contribuables et les anciens
contre immeuble ils payent les retraités
par exemple qui ne font pas partie du
nouveau monde selon l'expression
consacrée de la république au marché bas
ils sont amenés à à payer dans le dans
le nouveau monde et aussi des anciens
ministres et dans les anciens ministres
ya bruno le maire a donc l ancien monde
ça si l'ancien monde
il ya aussi un président de la
république qui lui-même a beaucoup fait
partie de l'ancien monde donc je ne
crois pas à cette à cette séparation je
crois pas qu'ils aient des français
utile et des français inutiles les
français inutile faisant partie de
l'ancien monde et où ea mobile ou
négatif vis-à-vis de toute avancée ou
tout progrès puis les français utile qui
ont tout compris au nouveau rien cadeaux
sur nous entend pas si on va un peu plus
loin que présente des appliques oppose
les français entre eux ces squats
s'enorgueillit je pense qu'il ya une
opposition et des choses qui sont faites
qui nous je pense est une sonde sont de
bonnes choses je les dispositions de
toujours objective et les choses mais on
voit bien qu'ils aient une opposition
fondamentale soit en frontal entre le
français l affaire de la csg clairement
est clairement dans cette danse est
énorme pour la tradition one ne peuvent
pas c'est donc la cg entre autres avec
le projet de loi de finances sur la
sécurité sociale est l'une des mesures
phares évidemment de ce budget de la
sécurité sociale c'est la csg à voit
tout cela et félix ul plusieurs sujets
ont occupé la journée d'hier dans
l'après midi le texte sur la suppression
du cic eux à échauffer les esprits pour
une question d'amendements inédit les
députés de gauche ont refusé de siéger
trois groupes vous informe qu'ils ne
participerons pas à ce vote et
quitteront l'hémicycle pour vous laisser
entre vous pendant que voter cette
mesure et j'invite tous les
parlementaires qui sont nombreux à
s'être plaint du fonctionnement ses
débats à en faire de même
la récréation a assez durée de
suspension de séance plus tard le calme
a été retrouvé l'amendement est passé
autre sujet débattu la suppression du
rsi tous les présents dans l'hémicycle
étaient unanimes pour dénoncer les
carences du rsi mais beaucoup se sont
inquiétés de la précipitation du
gouvernement
la décision de l'adossement au régime
général nous appelle à beaucoup de
vigilance notamment sur le devenir des
salariés du rsi qui ne doivent pas faire
les frais de cette fusion
je suis extrêmement inquiet par rapport
à ce qui va se passer dans les mois qui
viennent d'un point de vue simplement
mécanique informatique d'un point de vue
institutionnel
ça méritait peut-être un peu plus
d'attention et peut être même un projet
de loi dans la soirée l'augmentation du
prix du tabac a été votée le
gouvernement voudrait faire passer le
paquet de cigarettes de 7 à 10 euros en
deux ans on a un paquet de cigarettes
la hausse du paquet de cigarettes c'est
plutôt une mesure qui va dans le bon
sens eric woerth ya pas que des mesures
qui vont dans le mauvais sens non mais
je ne n'y a pas que des mesures qui vont
dans le mauvais sens on n'arrête pas de
le dire donc on peut d'ailleurs se dire
qu'on a une opposition qui est pas
suffisamment net puisqu'il ya des
mesures sur lesquelles on dit qu'on est
d'accord n'est d'accord sur le sur votre
sentiment
opposition qui est pas suffisamment net
jeudi on peut nous reprocher parfois de
ne pas avoir une opposition suffisamment
nette puisque on y ait des mesures sur
lesquelles on est favorable je pense par
exemple aux prélèvements voit la flat
tax à 30% c'était dans notre projet veut
pas dire qu'on est con et contre le
projet bien avant que ce soit dans le
projet de monsieur mâcon c'est vrai
aussi sur l' isf on est favorable à la
suppression lisf sauf qu'on conteste
l'idée et on pensait une très très
mauvaise idée de faire en sorte qu'il
reste une partie de l' isf mais
supprimer notre parti va évidemment dans
le bon sens me semble-t-il ya plein de
sujets sur lesquels on est en profond
désaccord en profond désaccord
cette affaire de la csg on est en
profond désaccord avec la ligne avec
elle il y en ad'autres le cic eu la
transformation du cce en baisse de
charge on est d'accord on n'est pas
d'accord coup passage le gouvernement et
vous en poche 3 milliards d'euros au
détriment des entreprises
je suis pas sûr que les entreprises les
très bien vu mais enfin il ya 3
milliards d'euros de flamber c'était
quoi
oui c'était quoi votre plante et sursaut
par exemple sur la csg vous êtes vous
n'êtes pas d'accord nous sommes pas
d'accord bernon mais pas fait ça on
n'aurait pas fait cet été primés on
n'aurait pas fait 22 2 milliards
d'augmentation d'impôts qui s'appelle la
csg est compensé par être en partie par
des baisses de cotisations salariales
ça ne sert à rien peut-être que ça donne
un peu de pouvoir d'achat aux salariés
dans un premier temps et puis ça se
noiera dans autre chose
nous étions favorables à une
augmentation de la tva dans le projet de
françois fillon une augmentation de la
tva de deux points hauts à 20% et mais
pour financer c'est pour financer quoi
bas pour financer une baisse des charges
salariales pour financer une baisse des
charges patronales pour faire en sorte
on pourrait se dire que ça faisait 3
carats car on aurait pu de c'était des
sujets qu'ils pouvaient être discutée
mais en tout cas pour financer très
majoritairement une baisse de charges
patronales
au delà du séisme
savait surtout un impact sur les
entreprises
je crois que les revenus d'activité que
nous cherchons tous à augmenter toutes
les familles cherchent à augmenter leurs
revenus ce qui est bien normal
et quand vous êtes en activité vous
attendent et non pas des transferts
sociaux vous attendez en réalité une
augmentation des remous créés par de
graves des tables et comme on est dans
un cycle économique formidable qu'aucun
gouvernement l'a vécue depuis bien
longtemps
franchement une grande chance pour le
manuel mac on la provoque pas et une
partie d'héritage d'ailleurs il invoque
pas donc ce cette croissance c'est plus
facile de réformer quand on est à 8 de
croissance que quand on les chaussées
sont pas changés rigole parce qu'il ya
la banque centrale européenne qui est en
train de modifier sa politique d'argent
facile est ce que ça peut avoir un
impact sur le budget qui est examinée en
ce moment non maman papa aujourd'hui
d'abord je sais pas quel impact serait
bien que nos mii que ça peut avoir l'air
on voit bien que la réserve fédérale est
déjà de le faire que la banque centrale
européenne probablement va le faire va
commencer à réduire les tuyaux avec
laquelle elle arrose l économie
européenne donc mais on va l'économie va
mieux
ce cycle économique au mondial enfin la
france commence à en profiter avec
beaucoup de retard
bon bah tant mieux le président m'a
qu'on arrive à ce moment-là il profite
de cette situation là il doit l'utiliser
à plein pour réellement réformer et
mettre l'accent sur la compétitivité
chez bien que le mot ils sont un peu
compliquées mais sur la sur la bonne
santé sur tout ce qui peut mettre en
bonne santé il aurait possiblement les
entreprises notre budget aurait été
profondément différent alors on quitte
l'économie et les finances pour faire un
focus sur l'actualité de votre formation
politique puisque les républicains ont
tenu un bureau politique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'exclusion dé constructif attendre à
leur éviction a été votée mais faute de
quorum ce vote n'a pu être validé la
décision officielle est attendue pour le
31 octobre céline 6 où on attendait les
pilotes du feuilleton mais hier soir
nouveau rebondissement chez les
républicains le bureau politique n'a pas
pu exclure les cinq constructif
faute de quorum ce sera acté
définitivement la semaine prochaine nous
assumons cette décision qui est
difficile qui est douloureuse mais il
n'y a rien de pire que la confusion en
politique
à la sortie les pros exclusion unis mise
la décision est prise le reste n'est que
formalité
allait il fallait en sortir les choses
ont été tranchées à une très large très
large majorité s'est très bien
maintenant on parle d'autre chose et en
avant par une reconstruction
nous avons voté leur exclusion ce soir
des républicains parce qu'on ne peut pas
être à la fois dans la majorité dans
l'opposition ceux qui ont voté contre en
revanche sont dépités ça m'inspire une
grande tristesse grande tristesse quand
je pense au bureau politique
je préfère m'en amuser que prendre ça
trop au sérieux
nous avons fait un choix de déplacement
sur la droite par rapport au projet
initial et puis surtout on n'est pas
clair sur sept ce lien avec le front
national sur le fn ce matin laurent
wauquiez candidat à la présidence du
parti à clarifier sa position
je n'ai aucune alliance et je n'aurais
jamais la moindre alliance avec des élus
du front national tant que je
m'occuperai de notre famille politique
je suis d'une clarté totale léa salamé
pour moi c'est hors de question de
rentrer dans ce chemin les ministres et
députés exclus aussi le entre rejoindre
en marche ou créer leur propre parti
comme thierry solère il y aura une offre
politique nouvelle qui sera proposé aux
français bien sûr que vous allez créer
un nouveau pire a probablement un
nouveau parking et des discussions que
nous avons avec nos amis d'aulus dei en
interne avec nous ce nouvel épisode
pourrait affaiblir encore un peu plus
les républicains qui ne parviennent pas
à se mettre d'accord sur la façon de
s'opposer au président macron et qui
révèle dans le fond l'existence d'un
vrai désaccord sur la place du curseur à
droite au sein du parti
alors on va revenir sur ces différentes
questions nous présentons d'avoir notre
partenaire du figaro jim jarrassé au
catch est venu sur le plateau eric
woerth une question sur cette situation
assez cocasse cette procédure
d'exclusion qui n'en finit plus pourquoi
tout ce tumulte et ce qu'on n'aurait pas
pu prendre des décisions dès le mois de
juillet pas il ya une procédure madhesi
nature on essaye de les respecter même
si ça peut paraître évidemment long
compliqué parfois un peu ridicule on
décide de le faire en tout cas ni même
aucune violence la violence elle est du
côté de ceux qui ont décidé du jour au
lendemain tu quitté les républicains et
de venir dans un gouvernement est de se
battre contre leurs propres amis de la
semaine d'avant quoi donc je pense qu'on
veut voir l'arrêt se peut donner le
sentiment d' d'un attentisme
c'est la politicaillerie pas ce qui
compte c'est qu'à un moment donné un
mouvement politique il doit être clair
s'il est pas clair ça marche pas donc il
faut je pense qu'on doit sortir de la
guerre que quand on sort de l'ambiguïté
on n'en sort pas toujours à ses propres
dépens parfois c'est nécessaire donc on
a besoin d'être clair et franchement
nono les ministres aujourd'hui issus des
républicains n'ont pas leur place aux
républicains et l'on choisit d'ailleurs
bruno le maire lui-même adhéré en marche
si je le crois le premier ministre il
peut pas être à la fois chef de la
majorité et membres de l'opposition
c'est assez compliqué on peut être
plastique open peut être souple voilà
mais il ya quand même on peut pas sans
arrêt faire des sauts de cabri peut pas
se perdre et du grand écart on peut pas
voilà donc il faut être clair et je
pense que la clarté c'est évidemment
qu'une petite les républicains allez on
va tout de suite retrouvé notre
partenaire du figaro
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jim je t'avoue si mickaël bonjour eric
woerth on connaît désormais les trois
candidats à la présidence des
républicains vous avez fait votre choix
depuis un certain temps il s'agit de
laurent wauquiez
il ya un peu plus d'un an lorsque
nicolas sarkozy s'était lancé dans la
course à la présidentielle à la primaire
vous étiez un peu écharpés avec laurent
wauquiez pour savoir qui allait assurer
son intérim vous étiez à l'époque
secrétaire général lui était vice toro
partie bon finalement c'est lui qui
s'est un peu imposé dans la course
aujourd'hui les favoris
il a bien joué laurent wauquiez non mais
ici imposée parce que j'ai moi je suis
pas candidat à la présidence des
réplicas jeu mais souhaitait l'être
c'était je pense que le désire il envie
de le rendre président et d'autres
familles politiques depuis certainement
plusieurs années donc il construit un
parcours autour de sa propre famille
politique moi je respecte ça c'est celui
qui en veulent plus et au fond celui qui
gagne c'est celui qui en veulent plus
ça a été un choix évident pour vous non
c'était pas un choix si évident jus de
même bon rapport à titre personnel avec
laurent wauquiez mais il ya des sujets
sur lesquels j'étais en désaccord mais
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il correspond
bien la situation politique on est en
convalescence on a besoin d'un sursaut
on a besoin de montrer qu'on est une
opposition responsable qu'on peut
écouter mon en temps et donc on a besoin
de quelqu'un qui est de la puissance
publique et la puissance de feu qui ne
sont pas allées ont décidé de ne pas y
aller donc donc d'autres candidats vous
choisissez le renoncer par pau je sais
pas que c'est pas un candidat par défaut
je regarde où je vois que le rang
wauquiez il a une sacrée puissance de
percussion et que si on veut ceci miss
france si on veut ce intermédié un
moment donné entre le dialogue singulier
saugrenue entre monsieur macro et
monsieur mélenchon il faut y mettre les
républicains qui sont à mon avis la
seule alternative possible à monsieur
macron il faut dans des démocraties qui
est des alternatives n'y a pas
d'alternative ya pas de démocratie
prenons un exemple précis cette semaine
à dans un meeting à mandelieu la napoule
laurent wauquiez a dénoncé les élites le
houle de la pensée des grandes écoles
par lesquels il est passé entre
parenthèses est-ce que vous adhérez à ce
discours
je peins j'adhère à l'idée que la
population française et la france peut
pas être géré par un clan sortie d'un
certain nombre de cabinets ministériels
et que la droite elle doit être
populaire elle doit montrer que la
france elle est gérée pour tout le monde
qu'on comprend aussi les français qu'on
comprend pas uniquement les lois les
règlements les textes on ne fait pas la
théorie oui que je pense qu'elle ce que
dénonce laurent l'idée d'élite c'est une
vision fermée la société tailler un
petit moteur en eau qui tourne au cadran
mais qui passe d'un poste à l'autre et
puis il ya ce faire je pense qu'elles se
risquent je ne dis pas que c'est le cas
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il ya ce risque
dégager mais autant d'énarques dans les
gouvernements dans les cabinets
ministériels et cabinets sont très peu
nombreux encore que les décisions sont
prises 13 ans au par quelqu'un qui n'a
jamais été élu sur le terrain il était
élu la était lui bien sûr à l'élection
suprême et mais qui au fond connais je
pense assez peu les français et connaît
la france je n'ai pas en cause les
intentions n'a pas le goût de la france
et des français n'aiment pas les
français pensent qu'il ne le pense je
pense qu'il ne connaît pas bien les les
français et connaît pas bien la france
les élus locaux les connaissent puisque
par principe on passe notre on a passé
beaucoup beaucoup de temps pour
correspond plus
je pense que le rand route je pense que
laurent guimier il va représenter une
famille politique de la plus large
possible qui représente la droite en
dansant dans son ensemble et dans sa
diversité avec laurent il a la puissance
de recréer de 2,2 de faire renaître
ça va quand même au positionnement
humaines de droite il pour lui de
rassembler quand on voit aujourd'hui sur
la question du front national il répète
à longueur d'interviews qui ne fera pas
d'alliance avec le front national etc
pourtant on a l'impression que personne
chez républicains ne le croit coûté six
mois c'est super à la mode toutes vos
questions c'est super à la mode en ce
moment on fait du wauquiez bashing bon
nous devons pas céder à tout le monde
aux actifs qui vont poser la question à
le mettre en garde en vue lors comme
tous les hommes ou les faibles on a des
défauts il ya des qualités et je pense
que je pense que ses qualités
elles sont elles sont assez approprié au
temps d'aujourd'hui faire renaître la
droite dans son ensemble donc on peut se
dire qu'il faut que les dessus ils
soient de plus en plus clair qu'il
représente l'ensemble de la droite du
centre droit jusqu'à la droite la plus
traditionnelle
comme ce qu'il est capable de faire
vivre en face des manuels macron avec
d'autres avec beaucoup d'autres faire
vivre l'idée que la droite de retour et
ce qu'il doit participer aux débats que
lui proposait à 9 ans il faudra en faire
de hambach on a déjà mais parce que ça
ne sert à rien parce qu'on a déjà vécu
ça au moment de la primaire parce que
les débats opposent
on ne retient que les oppositions et
puis c'est un ace et un sujets internes
aux républicains
chacun va dans les fédérations et
s'adresse aux militants c'est tous les
conseils qu'on reçoit de la part de gens
très intentionnés pour dire faites ci
fait ça ils n'ont en général jamais voté
pour nous ils ont voté pour monsieur mac
merci d'avoir été l'invité de par le
monde dont on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine bike
[Musique]